Game of Thrones provided unforgettable moments,
near-perfect episodes, and stunning seasons
throughout its run, but as it continued, it
also changed television in many ways, including
a few more subtle changes that flew slightly
under the radar.
As Game of Thrones started its run, it seemed
to have a clear main character that viewers
were supposed to rally behind, and that character
was Ned Stark.
As the honorable patriarch of the highborn
Stark family, Ned, the Warden of the North,
was lured away from his family and life at
Winterfell to head to King's Landing, the
capital of Westeros, to become the Hand of
the King.
In doing so, he splinters the Stark family
across the map of Westeros, leaving his wife
and sons behind as he and his daughters make
a new home in King's Landing.
However, things take a turn for the worse
when Ned discovers that the heirs to the throne
aren't actually the children of King Robert
Baratheon, but are instead the children of
Queen Cersei and her brother.
In the penultimate episode of the first season,
he confesses to his "crimes" in front of the
entire populace of King's Landing, ultimately
losing his head anyway.
Fans of the books saw this moment coming,
but for those who had just started with the
show, it remains one of the best moments on
Thrones, perfectly setting up expectations
before yanking the rug out from under the
entire audience.
From older films like Ben-Hur to more recent
epics like the Lord of the Rings trilogy,
movies have always been afforded the budgets
and scope to stage enormous action sequences,
but that opportunity has largely been absent
from television.
Even prestige dramas like Breaking Bad and
Mad Men, while beautifully shot, remained
relatively modest in scope, but all of that
changed with Game of Thrones.
Easily the most technically ambitious show
in television history, Thrones' filming spanned
continents, shooting in exotic locales like
Iceland and Croatia as it gave fans bigger
and bigger sequences.
"Those are brave men knocking at our door.
Let's go kill them!"
While relatively low budgets during season
one prevented the showrunners from shooting
battle scenes, that all changed with season
two's "Blackwater" which led to even more
expensive sequences down the line.
"Battle of the Bastards," the climax of Season
Six, set new standards, and in the show's
final season, the Battle of Winterfell ended
up becoming the longest ever battle shot for
television or film.
For years, television couldn't compete with
film on an epic scale.
Thrones proved it was not only possible, but
could yield some pretty unforgettable results.
Before Game of Thrones, it probably seemed
like a sprawling, dense fantasy series stood
little chance of becoming HBO's biggest hit
of all time.
Shortly after the show's premiere in 2011,
however, the network clearly realized that
they had a massive success on their hands
and got to work making sure that the showrunners
had as much money as they needed.
"And you will be speaking to me with more
respect."
Much of the added expense went to battle sequences,
with the Battle of Blackwater Bay bumping
the show up to a staggering $8 million for
the episode.
Even then, showrunners reportedly had to fight
almost as hard as their characters to get
that increase.
However, by the time the show reached its
final season in 2019, it was breaking records
once again with a budget increase that brought
each episode to a whopping $15 million, and
some episodes, like the one featuring the
Battle of Winterfell, may have even surpassed
that.
In recent years, $10 million budgets for prestige
TV have been doled out more commonly, but
a budget for the final season that reached
$90 million is pretty unprecedented, making
it clear that HBO would spare no expense when
the time came to finish off their signature
show.
With massive budgets reportedly already set
for the spinoffs, it looks like HBO has few
regrets.
For the first five seasons of the show, Game
of Thrones stuck pretty faithfully to its
source material, the novel series A Song of
Ice and Fire, by George R.R. Martin, which
is currently comprised of five books.
Named for the first book in the series, Thrones
tackled all of its biggest moments, including
Ned Stark's execution, the infamous Red Wedding,
the doomed wedding of Joffrey Baratheon, and
Jon Snow's death, before moving past its source
material in season six.
Season six came on the heels of a particularly
brutal fifth season, which contained some
of the most hard-to-watch scenes in the series.
Many critics and fans believed that once the
show could no longer follow Martin's strict
plot map, even though he was a frequent consultant
on the show, the quality suffered.
Whether or not it was truly able to hold its
own against Martin's books, it still marks
a turning point for adaptations.
Source material is almost always finished
by the time adaptations are filmed, so for
the showrunners to even attempt to move beyond
Martin's books while still maintaining the
story was a massive feat.
"Shock value" will always be synonymous with
Game of Thrones.
Viewers were traumatized by the Red Wedding
and horrified by Hardhome, but they could
also cheer as Jon and Sansa defeated Ramsay
Bolton at the Battle of the Bastards, as the
Night King met his defeat at the Battle of
Winterfell, or as Arya changed faces to get
her revenge on Walder Frey.
"Tell them the North remembers.
Tell them winter came for House Frey."
That being said, this shock value wasn't always
the show's most valuable or even enjoyable
quality.
Throughout its run, it pushed new boundaries
for what viewers could withstand.
The Red Wedding was bad enough, but watching
multiple episodes featuring graphic torture
scenes or the show's many instances of assault
as a plot device often felt like too much.
Even so, Thrones set new standards for shock
value, and if future ambitious showrunners
can learn something from its triumphs and
its failures in equal measure, it can only
improve the television landscape.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.